- Welcome to Introduction to Economics.
You are about to become an
economically-literate person.
You might not realize
this, but you've always
been an economic actor.
When you've decided to spend
your time doing one thing,
you might have foregone being
able to do other things,
that's an opportunity cost.
When you decided to buy something,
you might ask yourself,
why did I pay that price?
Would I pay more or less if
there were more of that thing?
Would I pay more or less
if there were more mes
who wanted to buy that thing?
All of a sudden, you're getting
into the ideas of supply and demand.
As we go into these lessons, we're going
to dig a little bit deeper at a little bit
of math, a little bit of visualizations,
where we'll see that these
simple but very powerful
frameworks apply to things
as complex as economies.
The entire academic field of economics
is studying how things should be allocated
when there's not enough for everyone
to get as much as they want,
that's known as scarcity.
How do you allocate scarce resources?
And to do that, you
have to make trade-offs.
We're also going to learn
about concepts of trade.
Why is trade good?
Ideas like comparative advantage,
but also why trade might not always
be in everyone's interest.
And as we go into these
and we study things
like supply and demand,
perhaps most importantly,
we're gonna start to learn
to think like an economist,
where instead of just
thinking about things
like prices and scarcity,
and supply and demand,
and everyday language, we're gonna think
about how do we model them?
Because once we can model them and think
about them visually and mathematically,
we can come to interesting
and rigorous conclusions.
Economics is sometimes
called the dismal science,
which some might view
as a bit of an insult
to the field, but I
view it as a compliment,
because what's interesting
about economics,
it has some traits that
make it a little bit more
like traditional sciences.
We're going to use some mathematics,
we're going to do some
diagrams, we're going
to be thinking
systematically about things.
But it has another aspect of it
that is a lot like the humanities.
We're gonna talk about how humans act,
and especially how they act in aggregate.
Even as we look at these models
and we try to understand
things mathematically,
we're always going to be asking ourselves,
well what assumptions
did we make to do that?
Is that true, are all humans rational
when they make these decisions?
Or are there animal
spirits that get worked
up where we sometimes
do irrational things,
where as a group, it actually could
be a little less predictable
than the mathematical models predict.
So this is going to be a fun
beginning to our journey.
And like always, if you're interested
in this topic and you want to go deeper
and you want to get practice
with immediate feedback,
you could look at all of these
lessons at khanacademy.org.